[vent qui souffle]
Salut à tous...
Oh ! On n'entendait pas bien !
Salut peuple des Internets !
Aujourd'hui je vous parle d'un jeu qui s'appelle "Code Names"
qui est édité chez Yellow.
Je sais que j'ai présenté sur le calendrier de l'Avent, 2 ou 3 jeux de chez Yellow.
Alors toujours pas de placement de produit, il n'y en a aucun sur toutes ces 24 vidéos.
Par contre Yellow, ils ont des bêtes d'idées de jeux à chaque fois.
Donc c'est pour ça qu'on la retrouvé plusieurs fois.
"Code Names" c'est un jeu dans l'univers un peu de "Agent trouble"
Ça ce n'est pas eux qui l'ont fait par contre, mais je vous en avait parlé.
C'est un truc d'agent secret, ou en fait on va fonctionner par équipe,
et on doit faire deviner des noms d'agents à l'autre équipe.
Je ne sais pas si vous avez regardé la série "Bureau des Légendes" qui avait lieu sur Canal,
mais c'est un peu dans cet état d'esprit.
Du moins dans le côté où l'on doit faire deviner des noms de codes.
Je vais vous faire voir ici, c'est beaucoup plus simple à comprendre.
En fait il y a des cartes rouges et bleues et des neutres, donc ce sont des personnages lambdas ou des vrais personnages de votre équipe ou de l'équipe adverse.
Et des mots.
Et la manière de faire deviner ces mots à l'autre équipe, c'est de passer par de l'association d'idées.
Par exemple, là il y a "champagne"
"pyramide", "licorne", "neige", "bretelles", "papier".
Pour "champagne", je vais peut être dire simplement... "bouteille1".
Ça veut dire qu'il y a 1 carte sur tout le plateau,
en rapport avec le mot "bouteille"
et que c'est celle-ci qu'il faut trouver.
Donc là c'est facile, ça va être champagne.
Et c'est comme ça que la personne va pouvoir retourner.
Mais attention, il ne faut pas qu'il retourne les cartes de l'autre équipe.
Et il ne faut pas qu'il se fasse démasqué en tant qu'espion.
Ces règles là elles sont un peu confuses et expliquées si vous n'avez pas le jeu dans les mains.
Mais je pense que vous commencez à comprendre l'essence même du jeu.
Le seul problème que pouvait générer potentiellement ce jeu,
ou alors les deux problèmes, c'est que: comment faisons nous pour jouer à 2 parce que c'est clairement un jeu déquipe,
et le deuxième souci c'est comment on remet la disposition, parce que la disposition elle doit être précise
pour que les personnes qui fassent deviner, sachent où sont les cartes à faire deviner.
Lesquelles sont bleues, rouges, etc.
Et donc il faut un positionnement spécial.
Là, ils ont eu une bonne idée, une riche idée même dirai-je !
Ils ont prévu 40 cartes clés.
Les cartes clés ont à peu près ce visage là.
Et c'est un placement qui va être aléatoire.
Parce qu'on ne va pas retenir les 40 comme ça, ça ne servira à rien.
Et donc on pioche ça au départ et on place les cartes en fonction.
Pour le côté impossible de jouer à deux,
ils ont créé des règles à 2 joueurs et ça j'apprécie beaucoup quand les jeux peuvent se jouer à deux.
Donc ils ont reformulé un peu les règles.
Pour y jouer à 2, c'est possible, c'est drôle,
c'est vraiment très sympa parce qu'il y a un petit défi de l'esprit.
Par contre il faut que les deux joueurs soient vraiment fair dans leur manière de jouer.
Parce que c'est très facile de faire perdre l'autre.
Le but quand on joue à deux c'est vraiment d'arriver à le faire,
c'est jouer pour jouer en fait, tout simplement.
Voilà, ça s'appelle "Code Name", je n'ai pas grand chose à dire de plus sur ce jeu,
si ce n'est qu'il est très sympa, il se joue bien, les règles sont faciles à apprendre,
et vous avez un lien dans la description.
A côté du lien, des places de spectacle pour l'Olympia.
N'oubliez pas de liker la vidéo si ça vous a plu,
rendez-vous demain à 6H du matin, abonnez-vous.
Ciao !
Bye Bye !
Au revoir !
¡ Hasta la vista !
On arrête là.
[musique]